hi everyone I'm Matt Walsh and I'm here
today to put a lot of fears to rest and
hopefully to begin the process of
healing for many of you and for me also
a few months back A Brave Young Man
confronted me in public about comments
that I made allegedly against the anime
Community what's your opinion on anime
it's really popular amongst teens and
young adults I think it's all satanic
words matter he informed me and although
I thought I was just a Man simply giving
his opinions about one of the worst
genres of entertainment this young man
let me know that what I was doing was no
less than one of the worst acts of
stochastic terrorism in American history
but he offered me salvation in exchange
for his contributions to further
childhood literacy I agreed to watch a
full season of the anime show one punch
man so if we started a GoFundMe to buy a
hundred books you would live stream you
watching a season of anime yes okay
on preparation for this event a special
chamber was constructed here at the
daily wire this Fortress ensures that no
one can get in or out during the
screening of this anime
what you're about to witness while truly
stunning and brave is also quite graphic
in Parts a true story of one man's
descent into madness and the miraculous
story
of his return
I know I've broken some promises in the
past but I'm now starting the process of
amending those wrongs I'm not the only
one who has broken some promises though
have you ever noticed how corporations
will promise you one thing but then give
you another take search engines for
example Google claims that incognito
mode allows for private browsing but it
doesn't actually hide your activity in
fact it doesn't matter what mode you use
or how many times you clear your
browsing history your internet service
provider your employer your school and
other unwelcome eyes can still see every
single website you've ever visited
that's why I never go online without
using expressvpn it doesn't matter who
your internet provider is in the US they
can legally sell your information to ad
companies a true violation of trust if
I've ever heard of one expressvpn is an
app that reroutes all of your online
activity through their secure servers so
that your ISP workplace or network admin
cannot monitor it expressvpn also
encrypts 100 of your data to protect you
from hackers expressvpn is incredibly
easy to use and it's available on all
your devices just have one button and
you're protected here's a promise you
can count on when you visit my exclusive
Link at expressvpn.com Walsh makes good
you'll get an extra three months free
that's exp r e s s vpn.com Walsh makes
good for three months free
expressvpn.com Walsh makes good
thank you
not not somebody died
it's been hours
lost all sense of time
maybe they'd forgotten about me
what if everyone left and I'm doomed to
sit here for an eternity watching
entertainment for the most tasteless
audience in history
no don't look at the time
it's a distraction
in at least four hours maybe five
just hold out for a little while longer
then look it'll be closer to the end of
this nightmare
the end credits
another episode in the bag
must be near the end of this torture by
now it doesn't make any sense
it's almost over
okay look at the time
shh
please
I can feel my grip on reality straining
every minute I spend in here I'm getting
weaker while anime fans get stronger
[Music]
that'll gain a deeper understanding of
their Community if I just watch a season
that's helpful
[Music]
not to stay strong
Brave is becoming left
bad is becoming good trying to break me
down
let me find my body I hope they know I
hold on until the very end
[Music]
I hope they know I watched as much anime
as humanly possible
I hope
I made it
much like the audience of the view I've
survived some of the worst torture a man
can endure
[Music]
was the anime Community right
I was watching a season of one punch man
opened my eyes to their art
their culture
no
it hasn't